لا أريد أن يعيد التاريخ نفسه ،
لا أريد أن أكون أبًا أعزبًا
، وبالتأكيد لا أريد
لأولادي أن يعيشوا بدون أم
أو أب ، العلاقة بين
أفراد معينين من الأسرة
وصحافة التابلويد
قرر هؤلاء الأعضاء المعينون الدخول في الفراش مع حق الشيطان
في إعادة التأهيل لإعادة تأهيل
صورتهم ، لكن في اللحظة
التي يأتي فيها هذا التأهيل على
حساب الآخرين ،
فأنا أفرد من عائلتي ، فهذا هو المكان الذي أرسم فيه
خط التسامح هو احتمال بنسبة 100 في المائة
لأنني أرغب في
استعادة والدي ، أود
استعادة أخي ، لم يظهروا أبدًا
أي استعداد للتصالح حتى
هذه النقطة ، ولست متأكدًا من مدى الصدق في
Burning Bridges ،
فأنت تعلم أن الصمت يسمح فقط للمعتدي
بإساءة المعاملة  حق مجموعة الأشخاص
التي كان من الممكن أن تساعد أو تمنع هذا
من الحدوث مع الأشخاص الذين
كانوا يركضون والذين كانوا يشجعون
حدوث ذلك أو بعض الطريقة التي كانوا يعملون بها
لقد شعرت بالتأكيد أن التنميط أو التصرف بدا لي
كما لو كان لسوء الحظ أن
القوالب النمطية كانت تسبب بعض
العوائق أمامهم نوعًا ما تعلمون
تقديم أو الترحيب
بالممثلة الأمريكية المطلقة ثنائية العرق ،
هناك جميع الأجزاء المختلفة لذلك
وما يمكن أن يعني ذلك اليوم الذي كانت فيه  مات
كان مجرد
رد فعل فظيع حقًا من أفراد عائلتي ،
فقد كانوا على قدميه ، وبعد ذلك كانت
الإحاطة والتسريب
والغرس كما لو كنا هنا
للاحتفال بحياة الجدة
وللحزن على خسارتها ، يمكننا  تعالوا معًا
كعائلة ، أجلس هنا الآن أمامكم
لأطلب عائلة
وليست مؤسسة أريد عائلة وأنا
أفهم كيف قد يكون من الصعب
عليهم أن يكونوا قادرين على الفصل بين الاثنين ولكن
بالنسبة لي كل ما شاهدته
وخبرة على مر السنين يجب أن
يكون هناك انفصال